both the film's protagonist and the
audience are constantly returning to a
massive battle between humans and Alien
Invaders on a beach this expansive set
piece was always meant to be a big
commitment on the part of the cast and
crew however that commitment was
originally supposed to entail just two
weeks instead it ended up going on and
on for almost three months the constant
delays stemmed from Lyman improvising
and making new stuff up as he went along
as if that wasn't enough of a challenge
the movie's big beach scene was filmed
on a man-made location this expansive
set took a lot of effort to keep
functioning over a solitary day let
alone multiple months having to keep
this set in working order not to mention
Emily Blunt almost breaking her nose
during all this meant that filming this
battle sequence was a trying experience
unto itself at least everyone involved
can Comfort themselves knowing that all
the Blood Sweat and Tears did result in
an immensely tangible sci-fi set piece
I'm glad we could work this out